we can't do this show without great
people behind the scenes stagehands
production crews and of course our own
Conan pages let's give them a hand yeah
they're great
they work hard behind the scenes I think
we're doing a great job
don't you Andy well I like pages one
through five but I'm not sure about page
six you know the one that looks like
Ellie Kemper oh yeah
I mean it I I do not trust page six
what portly la visitor was seen drinking
up a storm at Bakke o--'s last night no
names but our sources say he passed out
under a urinal and II couldn't be
revived
shut up page six
take it easy Andy weren't you a [ __ ] O's
last night yeah a lot of people were at
Bakke O's last night could we just fire
her please hold on Andy what else you
got page 620 coded Tom's are still
whacking after a certain hefty TV be
Lister yelled at a coat check attendant
at the Samba room last night
oh come on when she couldn't make change
for his hundred dollar bill the snippy
sidekick threw a 5 star fit that is not
what happened Conan this woman is bad
news look Andy I know she appeals to her
lowest instincts but I just can't get
enough you know anything else page six
which Boston born parrot topped
quickster paid $90,000 in black mail to
stop the release of his sex tape all
right I think we're done video shows the
freckled funny man in ten filthy sex
positions and he's all by himself
no no pretty good
pretty good get out of here page who
looks like Ellie Kemper
[Applause]
you
you